The joe rogan experience.
What was that kid like?
I mean it was,
uh,
it was frustrating.
They didn't like,
because I started when he started late night with Jimmy Fallon,
so I was one of the first guys there and they didn't like any of my jokes.
Like it was just,
it was,
it was impossible to mean or just like this is going to make Jimmy unlikable.
Luckily it wasn't about being funny so much.
It's like coming off as smart and uh,
and friendly,
you know,
unlikable the day.
That's what I was there for a year and then they barely used anything I ever
did,
but they knew I was funny.
They liked me and I thought for some reason in my head I thought that if I quit
before a year that it will like follow me.
People be like,
what happened with Fallon?
Why were you only there a year?
That like,
and then when I left it was like no one would have given a shit if I had left
after 10 weeks,
you know,
it wouldn't have mattered at all.
Yeah,
it was,
it was good.
It's an interesting experience.
But I did not enjoy it.
Being a writer for other people's voices has got to be very difficult.
It's,
I mean,
for me it's impossible.
It's like I write in my voice and you either like it or you don't.
Like I've written for Jimmy Kimmel,
Sarah Silverman,
and they'd,
if I love the joke,
they loved it too.
Uh,
but with Fallon,
that was not the case.
You know,
it was,
he was,
it was almost never like he,
he,
he would laugh at the joke,
but he be like,
I can't say this.
I can't do it.
What are they trying to do?
Like what,
what is he trying to do?
And he's trying to be like Middle America.
Like there's not a market for that.
Right.
Is that what it is?
He just wants everyone to love him.
You know,
he just wants everyone to,
uh,
everyone to love him.
And that's like not a bad trait to have in a late night host.
Right.
Probably the best trait to have an elite.
I noticed [inaudible] I'd like to see him drunk one day.
Just shitting on everybody though.
I think it'd be hilarious.
Hilarious.
Does it do that?
Oh yeah.
Cause I mean,
I,
I've,
I've heard that he quit drinking.
I don't know if that's true,
but he would like,
he liked to get drunk and like,
and like shitty bars and like hang out like with the,
with the staff and the crew like he was,
he's like a man of the people and he didn't just want to go home and drink.
He wanted to go out and go to some weird bar that was like in a subway that no
one knew about and have beers.
Like he was,
uh,
he was like a fun drunk,
you know.
But he did a lot.
Yeah.
There was always those rumors that he's got a problem.
She didn't,
he fell.
It's got a problem.
Yeah.
Do you think that's like the pressure of just being this like super friendly,
sweet guy on TV wanting everybody to love you?
Then you're like,
oh my God,
get me a fucking drank so I can cut loose.
I'm,
I think that could be part of it,
you know?
That's why I was,
I was thought like with my persona,
like let's be the meanest person you can so that you can,
it allows you to be nice offstage.
The other thing too is that,
how would you,
let's just say things are going to shit really quickly.
Right?
Right.
There's a nuclear power plant that's going to blow up any second,
any second.
How would you,
are you like a,
I know you're an outdoorsy guy.
You Hunt,
you kill harvest as they say.
Sorry.
How long do you think you could survive if things went to shit really quickly?
If you have to survive,
you have all the money you want,
right?
But like how long you think you could survive in the wilderness?
It would be very hard.
It's not easy.
And not only that,
you've got to get through the winter,
so you're going to have to build some sort of a shelter.
But it doesn't have,
to me,
there's no winter here that was there.
I mean,
um,
what's it called?
It gets here in la,
but in big bear,
which is only a couple of hours north of here.
Yeah.
I mean there's plenty of places where you could drive in a couple hours.
You could go to big bear and then you can go down to the beach.
You could experience the desert.
Yeah,
you could experience a lot of different climates.
It would really depend upon where you were stuck and what,
what you would eat.
So things,
if you want to stay in the La area,
you're dead because you're not gonna be able to eat shit.
There's nothing here.
Would you stay in your head?
Like would you migrate,
give your kids and you gotta get Outta here.
So you'd leave,
you'd drive your Tesla.
Which carbon?
No Way.
What?
It was a big debate that I had in the,
in a crisis situation.
Right.
Would you take the test or would you take,
what would your take?
I have a Toyota Land Cruiser with the VA gallon gas tank.
I got a apocalypse immobile,
but so now I went through a big debate.
I got,
I got shit on so much for this.
I said the same exact thing and like listen in a Oh shit situation,
I would leave the tussle behind.
Who argued with you about that?
Lot of people.
Uh,
I leave that behind.
I take my pickup truck like Tacoma,
that's what I deal with.
Gas numbers,
500%.
You know,
in an emergency crisis situation,
you don't have access to the gap.
What if the gasoline didn't work?
We'd go to the liquor store.
You fill it up with alcohol.
We'll run where we had the hurricane in Florida.
Oh,
now everyone's saying like,
yeah,
the gas pumps wouldn't work because the electricity was shut off,
but the superchargers still work and you could get to your destination still.
And like Tesla's use less energy.
It's like at the end of the day I happened to pick up truck with like two
shotguns and like five things at gasoline and be fine.
I don't understand that.
Yeah.
They also make tanks that you can put in your gas tank,
uh,
in your,
the bed of your truck.
The like the survival tanks,
the drive as far as you want it 800 miles.
Yeah.
And the more,
and they you drive thousands of miles.
There's a guy who actually,
there was a podcast that I was listening to this guy who is like an extreme
prepper and he actually made a trip with one tank of gas from Arizona to Canada.
Damn.
He drove all the way up to Canada,
all the way across with one tank of gas because this massive tank in the back of
his pickup truck,
right.
It feeds directly into his primary gas tank.
Yeah.
And you can get these,
they're like these survival tanks and you know,
they'll host like hundreds of gallons.
We're also a title.
I probably should,
I probably shoot it.
That guy's car.
That's what I think to do that.
So I don't know.
All of a sudden you're lawless.
See the lights go off for five minutes.
Want to kill everyone here.
Starting to fires shooting cars.
Yeah.
So,
so then,
all right,
so you leave,
you take your family,
right?
You have your kids.
If your wife were,
where are you going to go?
You hop in your Land Cruiser.
Where are you going to go?
You have a real powerful,
what are you going to bring you?
You would have to bring things to start a fire and things to kill animals,
right?
Those are the things that it would be very important.
Oh,
I would bring guns,
right?
I'd bring Bose.
I'd bring ammunition and arrows,
but I would realistically realize that,
first of all,
I'm not going to make more bullets and I'm not going to make more arrows.
What am I going to do and how long am I going to last?
You think marijuana?
No.
Okay.
No,
no.
I'd be just trying to stay alive.
Yeah,
but you'd also be trying to stay alive for a long period of time,
right?
You might want to bring it needs the pain.
No,
really?
it's not going to that.
I mean,
marijuana for pain relief.
I'm going against.
It works.
Yeah,
but that's not what I use.
A paint night of the impending doom here.
Yeah.
You'd be freaking out even more.
I'm freaking out.
Plenty.
I just can't wait til the day where they can do it genetically.
Where a woman really becomes a woman,
like a man becomes a woman or a woman becomes a man.
But guess what?
Even if they do,
here's the issue.
If you knew that a woman took steroids for 30 years and developed insane tendon
strength and muscle strength and then stopped doing steroids,
it is a scientific fact that you are going to keep a very big percentage of
those gains.
What are the game?
What is the percentage at 30% or 40% whatever the fuck it is,
whatever percentage that you would keep after you get off the steroids,
that is significant.
And even if you're not currently on these performance enhancing drugs,
your body has been artificially boosted to this superior level through these
drugs.
Yeah.
And you lose a lot of the feminine.
He lose the breasts does,
might not come back.
Uh,
well,
I mean,
I think if you take estrogen,
they'll probably call me.
I don't know how to fucking doctor.
I'm a moron.
But what I do know is when this is,
we're in nonsense land.
Yeah.
It's not,
it's not saying that someone can become a woman and be a woman and I'll talk,
I'll call them a woman.
I'll treat him like a woman.
I'm cool with it and I'm 100% cool with it.
I'm in this open mind is I come with this,
but this is,
this is unfair for women,
which is what's so ironic about this.
Yeah.
Because everyone's supposed to be looking out for women.
If you're looking out for women,
but you're also blindly progressive to the point where you let and shit like
this fly,
well now you're not looking out for women.
Right.
Because now women are in this weird position where you're putting them at an
unfair disadvantage.
Right.
It's fucking crazy.
I agree.
Was it the first one?
Yeah,
that was 43 and 51 days.
43 marathons in a row and 51 days with no training at a,
definitely.
I did have training that six weeks training.
Yeah.
Which is not a lot,
but they di,
they said that,
you know,
sometimes if you run a math and you should train for nine months before that.
And I thought,
well if I'm going to do 43,
that's going to be,
I haven't been training forever and I can't be bothered with that.
So I,
but you know,
and this happened to your civil war and maybe an any wool,
uh,
I,
I'm kind of so,
so encyclopedic about you will civil war and revolution motivated two,
but on the spot training,
you know,
training as you go along.
That's what I did.
The first 10 marathons trains you for the next 33.
What was it like when you got over the first day though?
The first marathon?
Preston's okay.
Fuck my first day is okay.
Well it's,
it's,
it's all in your head.
There's a,
um,
it's more mental than it is physical.
And so the first math that I've heard of people who are running marathons run,
walk,
staggered,
not very fast.
Get it done.
Boom.
The second math in his weight.
Cause you go,
I've done one,
I'm on the second.
And you can't really rejoice.
You come punch the sky.
You can't put a medal around your neck.
You're already,
you've got up at five or six in the morning and you're,
it's mid day and you're,
you're going through your second one and then let's do the third one.
And then you threw the fourth one and then it was raining and my feet was
shredding the oyster.
It was,
yes,
it made it too soft.
Yeah.
And they were rubbing on the,
on the running shoes.
And I didn't know how to,
how do I fix it when I'm actually wearing on it all the time.
So we started bathing in surgical spirit,
which you call something else.
Um,
it's a,
it's an ethanol,
methanol.
Anyways,
it's some sort of alcoholic spirits and it,
uh,
it takes the moisture out of your feet.
And,
um,
so it became like stones.
It's kind of,
um,
uh,
anyway,
if anyone does have some surgical spear,
if you Google it now you'll see what it's called in America,
but it's some sort of alcoholic thing that just removes moisture.
And so it made my feet,
my toes,
like little stones.
And kind of tough and actually that got us through and then I started and also
apparently,
cause I did 27 mountains in 27 days in South Africa in 2016 and that was,
the temperatures were crazy on that,
but it seems that the body was switch on a healing property that we've got
Leighton in ourselves that we don't use and you will heal quicker,
you will heal faster the more you get.
So I got you get stronger and both the British one and the South African one,
I got stronger as I went on the first 10 days of the other key thing.
And after that it's kind of easy.
You're used to it.
Your body just adapts and understands this crazy ass hole is going to do this
crazy also.
And the brain goes,
what kind of math than shall we run today?
As opposed to what the value you doing?
What kind of marathon?
Yeah.
Well I think that's what the brain's doing because the first day is going,
you got to do what?
This marathon,
but be okay the second day,
the way it's going.
Now we're going to s during another one,
third day,
fourth day,
fifth day.
This is insane.
And then the data and the brain going,
okay,
you're on this kind of cake or something.
I understand.
Let's,
let's try a betterment of this.
Don't push it too hard.
You know,
you,
the brain starts talking to the body and somehow it levels out around about
Maine.
Then they get surreal marathon.
18 wrath and 23.
I remember Madison 31 that was a level of meeting so weird.
There's a lot of this is subconscious behaviors that go on.
God,
why aren't people so God damn crazy?
I don't know.
Trauma,
you know what I call Yung?
Is it the call young,
uh,
fucking a line that says that,
which we don't work out in our subconscious.
We will act out as fate in our lives.
How about that?
Cause you will relive patterns.
You'll relive trauma.
You will relive these patterns and you'll do it on your own terms and you'll
wonder why you keep foe.
Why do you keep dating the same person?
Why do you keep falling into the same problem?
Why after two years is this go bad?
What?
What is that?
Well,
there's a way to actually creatively at least sit with that and observe it and
be aware of it.
That's what therapy does is even at the unconscious conscious,
it will direct your life and you will call it fate.
What a great quote.
Wow.
Until you make the unconscious conscious.
Yeah.
I mean there's a lot of fucking strings pulling on.
You will direct your life and you will call it fate.
Knowing your own darkness is the best method for dealing with the darkness of
other people.
Yeah.
Well that's a Nietzsche.
That's what I like.
Niches,
niches,
niches.
Idea was like,
look man,
you can have these false models of life,
which is a lot of times life is a bitch,
right?
And you're not going to,
you're not going be able to compete or you don't want it.
So what you'll do is you'll go,
it's okay.
Meek will inherit the earth.
That's all right,
I am,
but you have money.
But is he happy?
Is He happy?
You know,
there's a lot.
We make all of us do this.
We make excuses,
not live our best life.
And he was like,
Nah,
live dangerously.
And,
uh,
try to be the best you can be.
Just work your ass off.
And if you have to die,
if you have to take risks and die,
leave a good looking corpse is the idea of turn your life into a fucking circus.